Chancellor in the debate on the budget I
started by saying that I thought you had
been lucky because since you did the
Autumn statement in November Energy
prices turned out to be a bit lower this
winter because it was a bit warmer than
expected how lucky did you feel when you
saw the office for Budget responsibility
forecasts for this year
well um thank you chair I was quite
surprised when you used the phrase lucky
because
um I think it's been a very challenging
period overall for anyone doing my job
you accept that it was good luck
energy price guarantee didn't cost quite
as much as you were anticipating I think
it's quite important to understand what
the yes indeed the energy support
package for businesses and households
was less expensive than predicted in the
Autumn but it's quite important to
understand what the impact of that is on
our national finances it didn't in
itself give me any additional Headroom
for permanent changes to tax and
spending what it meant was that in the
coming 12 months we are borrowing a
little bit less
than we were originally planning to
borrow in order to fund those so uh
borrowing went up by slightly less than
planned which is a good thing but the
fundamental Headroom that I had to play
with didn't change significantly from
the Autumn statement which was after all
only a few months earlier
it's been what we call fuel Duty fiction
so in the Autumn statement last year you
had numbers in your fiscal forecast that
assumed that fuel Duty would rise by I
think 12 Pence this spring and none of
us thought that that was likely to
happen but you've now put that in your
numbers for next spring I think it's
fair to say that this committee is very
skeptical in an election year you're
actually going to raise fuel Duty by
that much and we note that the office
for Budget responsibility now highlights
that risk much more uh clearly in their
report
so you're not going to raise fuel Duty
by 12 Pence next year are you Chancellor
we don't know is the answer to that we
we haven't made any decisions I don't
agree that it's a fiction and the reason
I don't agree with a fiction is because
of what Paul Johnson himself said which
is that the cost of making it a
permanent change would be a reduction in
our in a permanent chain well it's not
if I may say just to give you what Paul
Johnson himself said he said that the
cost of making it a permanent change
would be a four billion pound reduction
in the Headroom after four years the
Headroom is only six and a half billion
that would bring it down to two and a
half billion which my judgment would be
too low and so we're not in a position
we don't we cannot afford to make that
change permanent so it's just not been
an option but did I want to do it this
year
yes I did because inflation is running
at above 10 percent and the combination
of that measure and
um extending the energy price guarantee
at two and a half thousand pounds for a
further three months brings the headline
rate of inflation down by 0.7 and I
thought that was an important thing to
do in a year where inflation is the
number one
destabilizing influence on the economy
so
um although some of that effect unwinds
the following year it's in a period
where inflation is predicted to be much
lower and I think it really is important
to get inflation down this year so
that's why I decided to do it this year
okay so next year when the office for
Budget responsibility uh predicts that
inflation will be practically backed
down to your target perhaps that will be
with a lower level of fuel a price at
the pump you're saying that you're going
to raise fuel Duty potentially by 12
pence in an election year of The Twelve
Pence rise was based on the level of
inflation at the moment so the amount
that it would go up by next year is
planned to go up in our numbers would
depend on what the inflation rate is at
that point but what I would say is that
um that is a decision that we will keep
under review and we'll make a decision
at the next budget and it will be
decided on the basis of uh the the room
we have
in our fiscal forecast the obr's fiscal
forecasts and economic forecasts at the
moment we do not have the Headroom to do
that so that's why we are not planning
to do it but of course we will look at
what the numbers say close to the next
budget and keep that decision under
review
you've got a very long wish list that
you stated in this budget you you you've
just uh stated that if you can you'd
quite like to not raise fuel Duty by 12
Pence um you want to raise defense
spending you aspire to that to be two
and a half percent of growth you want uh
to return the aid budget when conditions
are allowed to 0.7 if you'd like to keep
the investment allowance at 100 past the
three years that you put in your budget
the office for Budget responsibility
when we took evidence from them last
week said that basically your fiscal
rules allow a kind of one-way ratchet to
a higher level of debt in this country
because every time there is a bit of
Headroom you're going to put it into
those priorities and then when things
are worse than expected you're going to
let the deficit take the strain and that
way you know it's one way to an
increasing deficit which is completely
against the prime minister's priority
what are your thoughts on that ratchet
effect I would say two things first of
all
we have those fiscal rules
uh to make sure that chancellors are
properly constrained in the decisions
they take on spending so that they have
to make difficult decisions and indeed
it's because we have fiscal rules and I
think it's a good thing to have fiscal
rules that I took very difficult
decisions in the Autumn to put up tax by
25 billion pounds and to reduce spending
by 30 billion pounds so those fiscal
rules mean that
whatever those pressures are in the end
this country's chance of the exchequer
is required to make trade-offs so that
people can be confident that we are
being responsible with national finances
and that makes the job of chance I think
the office for Budget responsibility
said that it was harder for me to do
that than for any Chancellor that they
had ever
assessed the budget plans of because of
the fiscal situation but I think it's
good that chancellors do have to make
those trade-offs because I think it's
very important that we are responsible
with national finances But to answer
your what's the long-term answer to your
question chair it is growth if we can
grow the economy if we can get the
economy growing at a faster rate than is
currently planned if we can get
productivity growing faster then we can
get out of that Vice and that was why
this was a budget for growth where I
tackle the two biggest things that
business is up and down the country say
are preventing them from growing which
is investment incentives so with the
capital allowance it's 100 first year
deduction we have the most attractive
capital investment regime of any
advanced economy top equal to have 100
allowances and labor Supply which is why
we had the big labor Supply package and
we'll have more questions on that I'm
sure during the session I just wanted to
raise the letter that you sent me and
the committee this week about the office
for tax simplification uh one of the
things that your predecessor did that
you have not reversed is abolish the
office for tax simplification is that
because taxes are now so wonderfully
simple or is it because they've failed
in their task
um neither
um taxes are far too complex and there
is a huge job to do to make them more
simple and I intend to be a chancellor
who makes progress in simplifying the
tax system uh during my time in office
the abolition of the LTA was one very
major simplification in the tax systems
lifetime allowance yes
and I will continue to make sure in as
far as I'm able in every fiscal event to
try and make progress on tax
simplification so I'm happy to take that
as a personal responsibility rather than
have a separate group of people who are
funded to do that but if you're asking
am I asking my officials in the treasury
to do work on tax simplification
ahead of every budget and every Autumn
statement the answer is yes I just don't
think we need to do it with a separate
body
so the office was taxed
session is set
assumably therefore you would welcome
the opportunity to put something in
statute that reflects that change that
you've decided to make the appropriate
time yes okay thank you uh Danny thank
you thank you Chad thank you Chancellor
for coming I just wanted to ask a
general question at the outset about the
overall strategy and you describe growth
as the fundamental priority that will
address the economic challenges that we
face
you know the government that I supports
had a bumpy ride and the economic
strategies that we've uh that we've had
from the government in recent years I
mean there's been a whole list we
started this Parliament with the
industrial strategy we had to build
better plan for growth uh we had the
current PM's maze lecture when he was
Chancellor um
uh we we had a growth plan from
quasi-courting and then and then your
Bloomberg speech with a new budget
setting out your four priorities can you
just
in a sense describe the evolution of
economic or in a growth strategy over
the over recent years do you think there
has been a consistent theme or do you
feel it's been bumpy because the
evidence we took a few days ago from
economists suggested that one of the
great problems has been a lack of
coherence in economic strategy or do you
think that actually that we've been on a
fairly coherent path I think it's been
uh
more coherent than
um you might think with one exception
um yes there were some mistakes in the
mini budget which we had to reverse and
in particular I think it's clear you
can't fund tax cuts through increased
borrowing so that's a that is a clear
thing that we changed course on but
taking that aside if you look at uh
you know the industrial strategy you
talk about I think to say that we're
going to be the world's next Silicon
Valley and we're going to be global
leaders in clean energy Life Sciences
digital creative Industries Advanced
manufacturing and to set out how you're
going to do it in terms of improving the
skills base making sure that growth is
spread across the country
those are things that are what anyone
would call an industrial strategy
and so I don't think it's necessary to
publish a new document I just want to
get on and do it if you look at
the big decision
made by Boris Johnson's administration
at the start of the parliament to
increase Capital spending very
significantly
we have
honored that we weren't able to continue
the rate of increase that was originally
planned but we froze the increase at its
higher level in cash terms
and that is
um actually I should bring in cat little
because she's in charge of government
spending but I think that is one of the
biggest changes in government economic
policy in recent times that increasing
Capital spending so um at the last Sr we
increased Capital spending to nearly 600
billion pounds over the course of the
spending review period that is the
highest level of capital spending since
the late 1970s and the Autumn statements
and the budget reaffirmed that we will
have Capital spending at historical
highs despite there being as the
chancellor described some small changes
to the way in which we um have set out
the capital spending envelope overall
and that's a big decision to sustain
that level of capital spending over the
medium term in previous uh encounters
looking at how do you balance tax and
spend overall we might have chosen to
reduce Capital spending and so I think
it's quite critical for the growth
agenda that that spending continues at
historic High okay thank you well well
let me come on to one of the
consequences of that increased spending
which is our debt forecast the uh one of
the priorities of the government now is
to reduce the debt and just be
interested to answer or officials in the
forecast for that because we're looking
at
public sector net debt rising from
nearly 90 this year to
over 95 percent no nearly 95 in 27.
28 uh then then fractionally falling
I mean this this just this doesn't feel
like reducing debt to me we're trying to
stabilize it it's probably the best we
can say isn't it I think the accurate
description will be we are stabilizing
and starting to reduce debt
um you're absolutely right it is high it
is too high
and one of that is one of the reasons
why I didn't just spend the additional
Headroom created by lower energy prices
and we've ended up with debt levels that
are 54 billion pounds lower than
predicted at the Autumn statement and
our deficit will be 20 billion pounds
less in the final year than in the
Autumn statement and as a result of that
our debt interest payments on average
are going to be six billion pounds a
year less than planned at the Autumn
statement but those are changes that are
in the context of a national debt that
is still going up for the earlier years
and I think the context of that is a
pandemic where we spent about 400
billion pounds supporting businesses and
families
um that is not consequence free when you
make a decision like that but I think
it's the right decision because what
that's meant is that even despite the
disruption of the pandemic we've come
out with unemployment that's still at a
near 50-year low and I think that's a
big achievement
mainly because of my predecessor the
prime minister's decisions as Chancellor
okay
thank you so I mean the other
Consequence the other cause of the high
debt levels we have in my view is an
unreformed public sector that consumers
ever larger quantities of public money
and I wanted my final question to you is
to talk about public sector reform which
was the one of the great missions of the
conservative government that you were
served in from the beginning of our our
time in 2010 and feels to me that we've
lost the impetus there other things have
exceeded obviously but still I would
like to see you know I'd like to hear
from you how you regard public sector
reform as a priority for the government
particularly other chronic productivity
challenge that we have in the public
sector and and equally crucially that to
in my view the lack of a real Focus On
Demand reduction how are we going to
ultimately reduce the call on the public
sector through economic and social
policy so just on public health
productivity and then wider reforms that
might reduce demand
I very strongly agree with you and uh
when I was Health secretary for
um nearly six years after being
questioned by Mr Barron in a different
context I was a very strong believer in
public service reform in the NHS which
is our largest public service and
obviously it's not been possible to
pursue that agenda in the context of the
pandemic when we depended on the NHS it
was all hands on deck they did a
fantastic job
and we just had to concentrate on
getting through that once in a century
issue but now that is behind us and
we're dealing with a waiting list of
over
seven million people we are very much
thinking about public service reform and
that was why in the Autumn statement I
asked Patricia Hewitt
to do a review of the way the NHS is
structured and particularly my
long-standing concern that we have far
too many Targets in the NHS which make
it difficult for managers to run things
efficiently on the ground because their
hands are tied by by thousands of
targets we're looking forward to her
recommendations
thank you anything else maybe cat you're
in a position to I think and I've done
two things to this I think you're
absolutely right about public sector
productivity it represents a third of
the economy the rest of the economy has
recovered to pre-pandemic productivity
levels and grown whereas the public
sector is still lagging behind and
that's because of the chance uh the
context of the chancellor set out but I
think it means we have to work even
harder on the productivity gain at the
same time we've seen massive increases
in input so quite rightly we're
investing more money more people but the
demand to see the productivity gain has
got to be the focus and I think we've
done quite a lot of work to look at
input efficiency but I want to change
the dialogue in government to be as
focused on the productivity gain that we
get from the public sector now that
needs digital reform it needs us to
think about the balance of preventative
and responsive spend which I think gets
into your question about demand the best
way to go after demand is to think about
prevention rather than response and so
as we start to think about the big
questions of how the state operates
public sector reform going into an
expending review these are the sorts of
questions that we would want to be to be
focused on okay well just last week not
so much a question as a plea but last
time you were before us I raised the the
principle of payment by results and
outcome commissioning so I still regard
as one of the great Innovations in
public sector reform of the last decade
or so and again seems to have lost
momentum and I wonder whether we can
review that I agree with your point
about improving inputs and preventative
work but fundamentally we should be
holding people to account for the
outcomes that they deliver
and paying for results feels to me the
one of the great ways to do that you
were a little skeptical last time can
you
so I won't repeat the conversation that
we had last time I was here I really do
agree with you and that's why we created
the public value framework which is all
about focusing how we drive outcomes and
then work backwards to look at therefore
what's the best value for money to
deliver that outcome and on your point
about payment by results
um we are doing as you know a number of
pilots and it's important that we
evaluate those Pilots before we schedule
them for 10 years we know we know it
works but anyway some of it hasn't
worked which is why I'm potentially
skepticals as well as a lot of the
public sector current spending but okay
thank you thank you very much thank you
John thanks uh thank you the whole team
for joining us today I've been very
quickly following on from Danny's line
of questioning I completely agree with
the the focusing on outcomes as as
Jeremy will know we were you know we've
been banging on about this for a little
while and I'm delighted to hear that you
know that it's being focused on as a as
a priority certainly within the Health
Service anyway but can I just continue
with a few have done it Danny's themes
um before turning to inflation if I may
um
I put two Chancellor that there's a real
risk of the UK being squeezed by the
sorts of investment packages that are
being declared by the US and the EU
we've got the
um on the one hand we've got the
inflation reduction act with the US 300
billion dollars plus maybe more in the
EU we've got the green deal industrial
plan a little less but still sizable
money
um and this is all about as you well
know I'm encouraging energy security the
energy transitioning and safeguarding
key Technologies now
we've seen what you've done about the
investment allowance and the writing off
of it at Britain plant and Machinery
deducted in full for the next three
years how sure are you that's going to
be enough
given the initiatives we see globally
I mean I if I may add we've seen
AstraZeneca make a major decision about
moving offshore we've seen arm
um computer chip designer we've seen the
building materials giant crh deciding to
list
Etc in the US I mean there's a clear
indications that you know this may be a
factor in their decisions
um it's a very important question and um
I said in the budget that I would return
in the Autumn statement with a fuller
response and there was a reason for that
which is I want the UK to remain
competitive and I needed to see which I
wasn't able to do at the budget what the
EU response was going to be before we
formulated our full national response
and um
so we will return to this and we're
doing a lot of very detailed work I
would make two points first of all in
terms of the transition to Net Zero
clean energy economy by 2050.
it's a good thing that the United States
is taking climate change seriously and
there's a lot of catch up in what they
are proposing to do because
um we are even after the inflation
reduction act we are spending a higher
proportion of our GDP on the clean
energy transition than the United States
is so we're doing it in a different way
I happen to think a more effective way
through measures like carbon pricing
contracts for difference and so on
um and we've been extremely successful
we are global leaders in offshore wind
40 of our nearly 40 of our electricity
now comes from renewable sources the
second biggest Renewables industry in
Europe
but I'm very aware of the fact that even
despite that success which we should be
very proud of as a country
um you know this is 369 billion dollars
a subsidy
and there are risks as a result of that
and we need to mitigate against those
risks that doesn't necessarily mean
matching subsidy for subsidy but it
means making it for an overall package
which means people choose to invest in
the UK remains attractive I'm pleased to
hear what you what you say Chancellor
because this is going to be a moving
Target and and you sound as though
you're fully aware of that I mean it's
not just the big names what I would
suggest to you is there's a lot there's
a we we're leaders and very small Niche
technology areas particularly in the
green space
and one's hearing that you know those
smaller companies are thinking of making
the move but certainly across to the US
I mean we should ask ourselves why is it
that so many of our rising stars on the
technology front and the green front
were banking with svb for example I mean
it's an indication that there is a real
tendency to look at the states and say
look you know better tax and allowances
and so forth so I all I can do is
encourage you to think about you said
it's only the investment allowances are
only there for three years I mean the
sooner you can put an end to that
uncertainty to allow businesses to plan
once public finances allow then that
might be a good thing
um so could you please bear that in mind
absolutely and I made it very clear in
the budget speech that I would like to
move to 100 full expensing to be a
permanent change as soon as it's
affordable to do so but I wanted to set
out the direction of travel what I would
say is that although there are some
well-publicized stories of
companies choosing not to invest in the
UK
we are the world's sixth largest economy
and there is going if though uh well
we've been overtaken by India which I
think is
um perhaps not unexpected given the size
of the economy what I'm saying is that
we are the world's sixth largest
economies so there are going to be a
multitude of decisions that go in either
direction and even this year you can
point to decisions like Pinewood
investing in the UK another 9 000 jobs
because we've now become your largest
film and TV industry by on Tech the
people who made the Pfizer vaccine
saying they want to develop cancer drugs
once our temperature on the same
principal Airbus investing to build
aircraft wings for Air India these all
decisions that have happened this year
so I think there's a lot of positive
things happening yeah okay can I turn to
inflation very quickly
um Chancellor um you've quite rightly
said that it's the number one priority
this year I do suggest you that
policymakers record generally not just
in the UK but elsewhere has been woeful
on inflation I mean despite clear
evidence of pockets of inflation money
supply figures going up we were told it
wasn't a problem when it became evident
it was a problem it was always going to
be transitory when that became evident
that wasn't true it's now going to fall
away
um now I happen to be skeptical of that
I think well the inflation is going to
be volatile and higher for a variety of
reasons but how confident are you in the
obr's forecasts of 2.9 and that's going
to be met
I'm I'm confident in the forecasts but I
think you're absolutely right to say
there can be no complacency at all in
bringing down inflation and the reason
is because
a significant amount of that fall I
think 4.7 the last time I looked is
simply a mathematical result of
increases in food and fuel prices
working their way through the system and
then falling out of the index that
doesn't mean that those the prices of
food and fuel have fallen down to the
levels they were 18 months ago it just
means that compared to a year ago
they've fallen out but there is still uh
what's called because you know core
inflation which is driven by underlying
demand in the economy things like pay
settlements that's more than six percent
which I think is going to be harder to
bring down so I think there is
absolutely no room for complacency and
we need to really keep our eyes on the
target well it sounds as though you're
confident about the 2.9 so given policy
makers passed
record on inflation but can I put this
to you then if everybody's confident
about 2.9 percent
um
we've seen four bank failures we've seen
the rescue of credits please we've seen
wage growth inflation beginning to fall
away a little faster than I anticipated
so why then has the bank of England put
interest rates up
given that there's usually a time lag of
something like six to nine months before
rate Rises have any impact at the front
end in the economy it doesn't seem to
make sense it's for the exact reason I
said which is that they believe that
there is inflationary pressure
beyond what is automatically going to
fall out of the index
core inflation and that therefore they
need to continue to focus on bringing
down inflation through interest rate
Rises
and you know I think the underlying
reason but I might bring in Gwyneth
nurse who's my director general for
financial services
for those Bank collapses has been the
move to a world where people are now
anticipating higher interest rates are
here to stay and that I think is because
central banks remain Resolute in their
determination
thank you for that given I don't have
too much time can I just just remain
with you on inflation because if I may
in no disrespect meant goodness
um it does feel as though the policy
makers continue to be behind the curve
because if they were confident about 2.9
and given the time lag with interest
rate Rises do you not think there's a
risk that interest rate prices can go
too far given the reasonably fragile
state of the global economy
well I don't think we can have it both
ways and on the one hand be critical of
central Bankers for not raising interest
rates early enough and then on the other
hand when they do raise them say you
might be overshooting
what I'm suggesting is to transfer is
that they were too slow that they
haven't got to grasp the situation and
perhaps it's because of the processes
and techniques they use and the programs
they use but they were too slow in
recognizing inflation as a problem and
now they've got to the point where they
are overreacting
to the inflationary pressures there are
if you believe the obr's figures of 2.9
well I don't believe they are
overreacting I think there is still
inflationary pressure in the economy I
am very concerned about it and I think
we need to keep our eye on the ball
um you know only
a week ago we found that inflation had
actually gone up from 10.1 to 10.4
percent and I think that demonstrates
there can be absolutely no room for
complacency
foreign Angela thank you very much um
when you were last year Chancellor it
was um shortly after the um your
predecessor's catastrophic intervention
in economic policy and you were um
notably
um humble about the effects that that
had had
um he's now been seen touting himself
around for work expecting to charge ten
thousand pounds a day is that payment
for results that Mr Kruger was talking
about in the public sector I'm not going
to comment on that issue because it's
not relevant to my brief what I will say
is that he has said that he supports the
measures I took in the budget he thinks
they were the right thing to do and he
also said that you can't pretend that
the things that happened around the mini
budget didn't happen and so I think he
recognizes some of the things that you
and I talked about the last time we had
an exchange on the mini budget
that will try to stand meet your plans
um I want I want to ask if I can about
the current issue of Health Service pay
because as we know there was a deal done
on that the day after the budget even
though you didn't make any uh approaches
or or say anything about how these
public sector pay settlements will be
paid for
um why didn't you budget for the costs
of this deal and be transparent about it
because we don't no we didn't know and
we still don't know how much it's going
to cost
um when uh you don't know how much it's
going to cost because we still haven't
settled all the public sector pay
disputes there's um even within the NHS
the junior doctors
dispute is still ongoing we haven't
settled with
teachers and when we do settle there
will be a negotiation with departments
as to how much is born by additional
support from the treasury and how much
is born by efficiencies and
re-prioritizations within the department
the health sector has said that the deal
with nurses paramedics and others
obviously not doctors yet because that
hasn't been decided he said it's going
to be fully funded and those workers are
voting on it even as we speak as to
whether to accept it the treasury have
said that it's going to be got from
wider spending plans for the coming year
which implies cuts to other
departments so which is it well I
haven't
seen the words that you ascribed to the
health secretary so let me tell you the
government position the government
position is has with all pay settlements
that departments fund pay settlements
from the money they receive in a
spending review but in exceptional
circumstances there can be a discussion
with the treasury as to any additional
help and this is a different situation
because
um
because inflation was so much higher
than expected and therefore the pay
settlements have ended up being higher
than expected but there is a discussion
with departments as to how much help is
comes from the center and we haven't had
that discussion yet so that means that
the teachers have said that their
payoffer isn't fully funded is that is
that true as well then what would the
commitment we've made is that uh there
will be no reduction in Frontline
services
as a result of these pay Awards but that
doesn't mean to say that departments
won't make efficiency savings and
re-prioritizations and it's very
important that they should because we
have responsibility for
um to the taxpayer in a context where
we've just put up taxes by 25 billion
pounds and we need to be responsible
with public finances and fair to
taxpayers but I'm I'm also talking about
how you can be responsible and fair to
public sector workers who've had huge
real terms pay cuts even though they're
the ones that got us through the
pandemic in a lot of the key services so
there is some balance and there isn't
that Chancellor well that's exactly why
in the awesome statement we announced
I think the biggest ever cost of living
support package of averaging this year
and last 3 300 pounds per household
targeted the people on lowest pay a
package of support that amounts to
nearly 100 billion pounds it's a huge
amount of help so we are doing
everything we can to help people through
uh cost of living pressures but perhaps
I should just bring in yeah
stay with me if you wish but I was going
to give you a bit of expert with all due
respect have a great deal of respect for
you your experts and indeed worked with
some of them when I was in the in here
but I think it's right that you're here
to answer questions
um so as everyone is voting on uh these
payoffers that are going on now your
um your message to them is they are not
fully funded
um and indeed much of this will have to
be
re-prioritized as the Prime Minister
said from existing budgets which are
already very stretched that is your
message to those people who are voting
on whether they should accept these pay
Rises today isn't it no my message is
that we will fund these pay rises in the
way that we always fund pay Rises which
is a discussion with departments but we
make a commitment that there will not be
a degradation or Frontline services for
the public and we will make sure in the
way that we fund these settlements that
we're able to do so in a way that honors
that well I hope that that will be true
and we'll certainly see how that works
out as these things go on and in your
budget speech you said taken together
today's measures lead to a slightly
lower overall tax burden for the rest of
the parliament compared to the obr's
Autumn forecast but actually chart 4.1
of the obr's forecast shows that taxes
are proportion of GDP is higher
after the budget than it was in the
Autumn statement so why did you claim
that it was lower
um I'll bring in Sean Jones to talk
about the exact numbers but the it is
true that as a result of the measures
that I took in the budget the tax burden
as a proportion of GDP does fall
slightly but it is in a context of the
overall tax burden increasing because of
the pressures that we have on the public
finances so I was
being very careful to explain that the
direct decisions that I took in the
budget by the way if you chose a
three-year period rather than a
five-year period there's quite a
significant reduction in tax burden
because that's the period that we're
having full expensing for Capital
allowances but if you go
to the full five-year period there is a
small reduction but maybe Sean you can
just clarify the exact numbers on that's
right John so I think the ABR said that
the tax burden comes down as a
consequence of your policies by 0.3
percentage points between 23 24 and 25
26 and 0.1 percentage point in the final
year as a result of policies in the
budget as you say
um I think most people will
experience something slightly different
because of your stealth tax with frozen
thresholds
um which raised 119 billion over five
years but
um are going to according to
analysis ensure that six million people
are dragged into higher rates of tax
because of the freezes
um and that's the equivalent of four
Pence on income tax why weren't you more
upfront about the effect that this
stealth tax by freezing thresholds would
actually have on ordinary people I was
completely upfront and I think I said
even this morning that in the Autumn
statement I increased taxes by 25
billion pounds I never hidden from the
difficult extremely difficult decision
that we took extremely difficult for me
as a conservative because we want to
bring down tax rates but what I would
say is that if you look at why not
put it on put it on the basic rate if
you freeze thresholds it happens
stealthily you accept it surely well I
happen to think this is a better way of
doing it and let me say to you I've been
completely up front never hidden the
fact that we've extended the fresh UPS
of the threshold freeze but overall one
of the things that I'm most proud of is
that since 2010 because of increases in
the threshold for both tax and National
Insurance someone on the average salary
000 pounds a year is paying a thousand
pounds less tax and National Insurance
than they were paying in 2010 that's the
aggregate impact of our commitment and
what I would simply say is that
the conservative approach is that we
bring down taxes when we can but always
in the context of being responsible
about public finances that's what we did
with the increase in the income tax and
National Insurance thresholds that's
what I did with corporation tax this
time with the nine billion pound annual
reduction for the next three years
and we would like to continue to bring
down taxes when we can which is why we
had a growth budget which we think gives
us the best chance of doing that you
accept that tax rates were at their
highest for 70 years while you're busy
saying you want to bring them down as a
proportion of GDP I accept that
following a once in a century Global
pandemic and a once in a generation
energy crisis one of which has cost us
400 billion pounds in the other that's
cost us more than 100 billion pounds if
you include the support for businesses
yes I accept the tax burden has gone up
for the moment but I want to be bring it
down and that's why the focus in the
budget was unlocking our long-term
economic growth rate through addressing
labor Supply and business investment and
just one very final question which
should which should elicit I hope quite
a quick factual all answer how many
couples are going to lose access to
child benefit because of your stealth
taxes on the threshold which will take
them above
I'll have to write to you with the exact
number because I don't have it to hand
but what I will say is that I think most
working couples
will say that the measures in the budget
were going to make an enormous
difference to them because of the child
care Provisions which if you've got a
child under five we'll see child care
costs Falling by up to sixty percent six
and a half thousand pounds so I think
we've done everything we can to help
people that are very challenging stage
of their life thank you Angela
5 billion fiscal consolidation after the
mini budget Fiasco on top of the other
costs the 400 billion and the energy
crisis I think I did actually because I
said it was 30 billion pounds of
spending increases
to remind everybody when you were
listing the 400 just to name Angela the
400 billion uh and the and the various
costs
um that's about a billion pounds a day
over a billion pounds a day in the 49
million 49 days uh in the former prime
minister's time in office but I did
mention it just to be clear I mentioned
it earlier in the session I talked about
that consolidation very clearly okay and
and that was as a direct consequence of
the mini budget Fiasco under the last
Chancellor
and prime minister
um before we go on to I want to ask you
some questions about living standards
but before that I just wanted to pick up
on the um Sir John vickers's the
comments is also on the Edinburgh
reforms in his evidence he said in my
view moving room fencing would pose a
very great risk to financial stability
the governor governor yesterday agreed
with that as dear to some wood to the
pra do you agree with that
okay can I just sorry your
your earlier comment about the 55
billion pound consolidation being a
direct result of the mini budget I I
don't accept that
um that was a concern I had an emergency
budget last November when you became a
chance
to the British public I've accepted that
mistakes are made in that mini budget
and we reversed them but I don't accept
that the consolidation that we had to
make in public finances was as a result
of that it was as a result of underlying
factors that we had to address which is
the 400 billion okay um
we'll take it outside after this session
because I've only got a few minutes
sounds like a gentleman's club if we're
going to take it outside and to carry on
but if that's what you wish Miss Ali I'm
very happy to do so I just admit I just
meant we can continue debating that
outside
um uh because I've got I've got a few
questions
very important Edinburgh reforms
Chancellor
um uh do you have any plans to remove
ring fencing now or need any time in the
future because in the in the document
there was a reference to
um the possibility of it being removed
in the future
yes um so we do think that 15 years
after the financial crisis
um it's the right time to review the
ring fencing regime and we've had a very
thorough review being done done by Keith
skioch and we're going to announce some
reforms uh based on the recommendations
that he has made but we have also been
very clear that we will not unlearn the
lessons of the financial crisis in 2008
and we will
make sure that we build on the fact that
for example for the first time our
Regulators have a responsibility to
promote Financial stability that is
extremely important and we will make
sure that nothing we do compromises that
you're not seeing a straightforward no
to to removing you you're saying that
can you just say yes or no whether you
plan to at any point in the future
removing fencing because the governor
yesterday said that ring fencing along
with other Provisions you know is a
complement complementary provision
that's very important and removing it
would pay as a risk to financial
stability in the document the Edinburgh
reforms document that Sir John Vick has
um pointed to
um uh the the fact that the government
has said that while it is worth
retaining ring fencing for now there
might come a day when resolution can do
the job instead that would be the wrong
approach are you saying that ring
fencing
um will remain or are you considering
resolution doing the job instead
well I apologize to the fact that
because we haven't announced exactly
what we're going to do yet I can't tell
you uh now in front of the committee
exactly what we're gonna do but what I
can tell you is that we're would you
like me to tell you what I can tell you
we are not going to turn the clock back
to 2008 and unlearn all the lessons from
that and you're not answering the
question Chancellor with respect I'm
asking you a specific question about
whether you plan to get rid of remove
ring fencing despite the despite the the
points that the governor has made so
John Vickers has made and in fact sir
Keith had said as well that that would
be a propose a risk to financial
stability I think that people would want
to know not least we could give them the
recent Financial turmoil that you have
no plans to remove ring fencing that it
remains as a complementary provision
that The Regulators believe that is
necessary as I've said we will bring
forward our plans shortly that is not
this morning but we will bring forward
our plans shortly and then we will
answer those questions but the
reassurance that I want to give everyone
is that we will not do anything that
compromises Financial stability we will
not unlearn the lessons of the financial
crisis we won't turn the clock back sure
but that you're you're not re you're not
providing the reassurance that the
governor The Regulators need that you're
not going to be removing ring fencing
which is concerning in my view no I
think I'm reassuring people do we have a
date for that announcement uh Chancellor
I think we've said in government Parts
shortly or soon or we've used a phrase
like that haven't we that we're very
good at using in government we are we're
certainly I mean we will consult on the
the uh specific skill reforms in the
summer so there will be a paper on that
uh taking forward those specifics the
there's a call for evidence out now on
the uh comparison between ring fencing
and resolution and
um once we've once we've analyzed the
responses to that call for evidence
we'll come back on that later later this
year thank you um turning to living
standards the obr conceded that the the
British families are now facing a
two-year long six percent squeeze on
living standards
um which is expected to be lower in 2026
than 2019.
um can you can you explain why the
budget prioritizes giving 4 billion uh
four billion pounds a giveaway to the
wealthiest view uh do you do you think
you've got your priorities right
Chancellor well um that is not what the
budget prioritizes and uh that's a
mischaracterization of budget measures
so let me just recognize this would you
let me answer the question but hang on
you recognize the squeeze on living
standards yes I was about to come on to
that I very much recognized the squeeze
and that's why there was a large number
of cost of living measures in the budget
um
first of all the energy support package
3 300 pounds per household nearly 100
billion pounds over uh this financial
year and the next financial year
um then there was uh the fuel Duty
freeze uh there was measures to help
people on prepayment meters there was a
very long list of things to help people
with cost of living pressures and we
want to do everything we can we stand
ready to do everything we can to help
people with those short-term pressures
but yes after you've been through an
energy crisis after you've been through
a pandemic there is pressure on living
standards and the the long-term
sustainable way
to be able to relieve that pressure is
economic growth and the way to do that
one of the biggest levers that
government can control is to remove the
barriers that stop people who want to
from working that's how you increase not
just GDP but GDP per head which means
that you have more money for public
services you can keep taxes lower and so
on and the reason why what you said was
a mischaracterization is because the
pensions lifetime allowance
is from memory about 700 million pounds
a year the child care reform that we
announced is more than 5 billion pounds
a year so if you're saying where did we
prioritize we prioritized helping
Working Families young families who want
to to get back to work if you look at
the background this committee produced a
report some years ago about child care
during during the time that your party's
been in government and many of the child
care Provisions had been had how many
Child Care organizations have had to
close over the last decade so you're now
playing catch-up having made Cuts in the
past but going on to the point about who
benefits the the the
your you know your own forecasters say
that about 15 000 people will be
receiving 250 000 pounds each in terms
of tax reliefs okay by contrast what we
have is nothing in the budget for 200
over 270 000 people who are homeless 14
million people are still living in
substanding house standard housing uh
7.5 million people will still be in fuel
poverty nearly 10 million adults already
are skipping or cutting back on meals
and six in ten adults are unable to
afford Basic Essentials Chancellor this
is after 13 years in government and this
is after what you're telling us you have
done as Chancellor and I recognize you
had to clean up the mess of your
predecessors and I think there's a sigh
of relief in the country that you
haven't crashed the economy as well but
over a decade and this is the this is
the situation in this country this is
what people are having to live through
what are you going to do about it
because it's not good enough what you've
done okay so far so let's just go
through the points you've made there
first of all
um I completely reject the suggestion
that our child care reforms are playing
catch up uh when we came into office
there was no uh 30-hour offer for three
and four-year-olds that was introduced I
believe in 2013. I was very proud that
we introduced that we didn't have that
before that made a very big difference I
have now extended that offer to
babies over nine months and two
one-year-olds and two-year-olds and that
is a very big change in child care
provision which will bring us much
closer to countries like Denmark and
we'll remove a huge barrier to two and a
half years we'll remove a huge barrier
can I answer the question please and yes
because it's a huge a huge increase in
child care provision there needs to be a
very big increase in Supply you need
thousands more if I could answer the
question please you need thousands more
child minders thousands more nurseries
thousands more Nursery places and that
takes time and you can't do that
overnight but by September of next year
a million parents will be benefiting
from this reform who wouldn't otherwise
the benefit can I can I answer the rest
of the can I answer the rest of the
questions Miss Ali because you talked
about something which is very important
health we can we can you can either let
me answer the questions or not but you
are something on child care and you also
then asked a very important question
about what we're help doing to help
people who are disadvantaged and what we
announced in the Autumn statement and in
the budget was a package of nearly a
hundred billion pounds it's simply not
uh reasonable to say that giving on
average
3 300 pounds per household but let's be
clear that is an average number it is
weighted to people on the lowest pace so
people for example
um on Universal Credit uh we'll get a
one-off payment of 900 pounds pensioners
300 pounds uh people with a disability
150 pounds uh then there's the help with
their energy bills on top of that then
there's the help with prepayment meters
and if you ask me uh will you ask me a
bigger question about what's happened
after over 13 years the answer is that
the number of people in absolute poverty
after housing costs has gone down by 1.7
million including 400 000 children so I
think we have made a very big effort one
of the reasons why that's happened
is because there are a million fewer
households where no one is in work and
that has that is demonstrably makes a
big difference in reducing poverty rates
have got questions on uh related topics
so Andrea thank you chair good morning
Chancellor
um I have five questions really Keen to
get through them the first one is
although economic participation is high
relative to oecd in the UK
why is it do you think that
post-pandemic economic inactivity has
risen the most in the UK out of all G7
economies
it's a really important question to
answer because
post-brexit when we're not part of the
single market and you have businesses
with 1.1 million vacancies uh then I
have to answer the question as
Chancellor as to how people are going to
find the labor that they need and
um what are the barriers and they're
actually seven million adults
of working age who are not in work of
whom some will have disabilities that
mean that they cannot work and we should
support them uh generously as a society
but um I think there are some factors I
think um we have declined particularly
in the over 50s who take early
retirement and that's something that the
governor uh talked about yesterday and
um one of there are various reasons why
people do there are things that we have
no control over people have paid off
their mortgage they make a lifestyle
choice they decide uh they don't wish to
work anymore but there are other people
including a large number of doctors who
say that the way pension taxes work has
prompted them to retire earlier when
actually they would have been willing to
carry on working and that's why we made
the decision on the lifetime allowance
thank you and that all makes sense to me
but my specific question is why is
economic inactivity so much greater in
the UK relative to other oecd countries
post pandemic you know that's all a
factor for every other oecd country too
do you think is that something you're
looking at or is it just
I don't think it is I mean we're I think
15th in the oecd out of 38 countries so
we're sort of middle of the pack
um pandemic is it so pretty pandemic
yeah no post pandemic is it because we
were so generous with furlough that
people have enjoyed a much more relaxed
lifestyle don't want to go back to work
anymore except to lower lower standard
of living as a result obviously the
facts are that a huge number of people
the biggest area of growth is people
citing long-term illness
um disability as the reason is that
because they are being honest about
their problems now or is it that
people's mental and physical health is
is so much worse now than it was do you
have some of those answers Chancellor
um well I think we have some of them but
not all of them and it's something we
continue to look at
um just to
um
go back to the early retirement issue
that although we're 15th in the oecd
when it comes overall economic
inactivity when it comes to over 50s
we're 22nd and that is an area that has
fallen quite significantly uh post
pandemic and that's why we thought that
was an area but I think you're
absolutely right to focus on the two and
a half million people who are long-term
sick and disabled
and um that's a number that has grown
and we believe I believe that we need to
completely rethink our approach I'm very
proud of the reforms that Ian Duncan
Smith introduced which mean that there
are two million more disabled people in
work but I think our understanding of
the work that someone with a sickness or
a disability can do has changed
dramatically with the possibilities of
working from home Zoom teams and so on
and so we need to rethink that and
that's why the white paper the DWP white
paper announced announced the abolition
of the work capability assessment
because we think we need to overall that
thank you that takes me on neatly to
that so anecdotally I have constituents
coming to me who who particularly women
over 50s saying no one will give me a
job I'm just like this is ridiculous
you're perfectly competent and capable
person why Won't Anyone give you a job I
also get people coming to me with
disabilities saying no one will give me
a job so absolutely I think you're on
the right track to be focusing on what
more can we do not just with the with
our own
um reforms and helping people into it
but also perhaps with businesses what
are we doing to incentivize businesses I
don't know whether you can say a bit
about that absolutely
um and yes I think that we need a change
in attitudes among some businesses
although there are other businesses
that are very enlightened in this
respect but if I give you an example
um this week I hosted a reception in
number 11
for a charity that puts young people
between 18 and 25 with learning
difficulties into work placements it
supports them for a year and the deal is
that at the end of that period they have
to be interviewed in exactly the same
way that anyone else will be interviewed
and only given a job if they qualify for
it and they have a 65 success rate in
placing people with learning
difficulties into
full-time jobs it's an amazing project
and that is because the process of
supporting someone into employment
actually changes attitudes amongst the
employers as well and they realize that
uh
people have an enormous amount of value
to add to their organization in a way
they might not have understood before
thank you thank you changing the subject
completely do you accept that giving
families better support from pregnancy
through to two will lead to a more
economically productive but also a
happier Society in the long run would
you accept that as a thesis yes thank
you so what will your child care
policies do for those families where one
parent wants to care for their own
preschool children
well um first of all
there are a lot of families who are
under Financial pressure and they want
to resolve that by both parents working
and I think that can make a very very
big difference to the life chances of
children
if they're able to relieve that
Financial pressure now obviously it's a
matter of choice if someone chooses to
stay at home but I would point out that
for the poorest families who are the
children who we most worry about in
terms of
being held back in their life chances at
a very young age we've also in the
budget made very big provision for
families on Universal Credit
to help them and we think that there are
a number of families where you can make
a positive intervention to a child's
life chances by putting them in a stable
Child Care environment and so I think
this this budget will have a big impact
for them the answers Andrea is nothing
because unless both parents
families a nurturing Child Care setting
is absolutely vital so not to detract
from that at all but there's equally
millions of parents where actually they
prefer out of choice they believe it's
the right thing for their baby their
infant to be cared for at home in a home
setting your policies do a lot for child
care settings in nurseries relatively
little for child minders and nothing for
parents who perhaps want to work shift
so that there's always one parent at
home but that the child could be cared
for perhaps by a child minder or by
perhaps a grandparent and will you be
looking again at more flexibility for
families and including will you look
again at child benefit to to look at how
families can perhaps um make those
choices for themselves rather than just
going with State provision we looked at
everything that we were affordably able
to look at but I would say that for
example on child minders we took some
very specific measures to increase the
supply of child minders with 600 and
1200 pound bonuses for registration as a
child minder because we
you know listen to colleagues like
Siobhan Bailey who talked about the
issues there when it comes to parents
who work shifts we have the tax-free
child care system which means that
people can get tax relief on their child
care even if it's being provided in the
middle of the night or at unconventional
hours so there's a lot of support
already in place but this was a huge
increase in support which I think will
make a very big difference particularly
to children in the lowest income
families
and will you continue to look at what
more can be done to support families
through the tax and benefit system we
will and we'll continue to listen to you
because you're one of the loudest voices
in that area thank you thank you and
thanks Douglas yeah thanks very much
good morning and uh Chancellor the in
the speech you had at Bloomberg in
January this year you said that
structural issues like product
productivity skills gaps low business
investment and an over concentration of
wealth in the Southeast have led to
uneven and lower growth
um you know I I see a mismatch between
these words and what I read in the in
the the budget statement so how did
these or how did the budget actually
help solve some of these problems well
um a lot of things actually
um first of all it's important to say
since the leveling up agenda started uh
70 of jobs salary jobs have been created
outside London and the southeast
secondly I think it's important uh to
give the government credit for what
we've not done given the financial
constraints that we Face we've not for
example canceled hs2 which is going to
make a big difference to the leveling of
agenda by improving connectivity between
North and South
there were a lot of uh leveling up
initiatives announced in the budget but
I think the ones that will make the
biggest long-term difference in
spreading wealth creation throughout the
country are the 12 investment zones in
our highest growth industries that will
be setting up around the country
including in Scotland
right the in terms of the the budget
though when if we go back to that and
what specifically was in that for some
of the regions of England for whale for
Scotland for Northern Ireland but you
can point to to say this is actually
going to be the Game Changer in terms of
getting the country if you're looking
for high growth and you're looking for
or sustainable growth but what was the
what is the real drivers that you've
missed out on on this budget because it
seemed to be fairly weak in terms of
where you're taking things
I don't agree I mean I talked very
specifically at quite some length in the
budget about the success of Canary Wharf
um in terms of regenerating the East End
of London and my desire to have 12 mini
Canary wharfs outside London and the
southeast including in Scotland and I
spoke at length at the support we're
giving to our high growth the money you
put into that is fairly small beer in
terms of you know what we need to do as
a nation to actually get that level of
growth that that you want so you know
there's there's an insufficient
investment being made in these areas
that you're suggesting is it's not it's
a tiny Hammer to crack a huge knot and
you know it's just it's just not going
to cut it at the end of the day
I don't agree with the greatest respect
um because you can't look at the
investment Zone policy the mini Canary
wharfs in isolation from the other
things we're doing to turn this country
into Europe Silicon Valley the huge
investment in an exascale computer for
example the overhaul of Life Sciences
regulation and what we're doing is
creating an environment where life
sciences companies digital technology
companies clean energy companies
creative Industries are investing in at
scale in the United Kingdom and what
we're creating is 12 investment zones
across the UK for them to invest in so
just to finish because it is I
understand why you ask the question and
I know you asked it with with great
sincerity but if I could give you an
example of a conversation I had
yesterday
with representatives from the life
sciences industry who say much as they
love Cambridge and Cambridgeshire they
find it very difficult to get lab space
if we are going to continue to expand
where Europe's largest Life Sciences
sector they need space outside London
and the southeast to do it so it's part
of our plan to build our life sciences
industry to give attractive places for
people to invest throughout the UK
you mentioned about connectivity as well
in terms of driving productivity but if
you do look at hs2 and I was glad you
actually mentioned it too because we're
absolutely silent about it during the
the budget but as it says to hit the
buffers I mean is that at the end of the
line as it were in terms of taking the
project forward because it seems to be
we've got vast cost overruns and you
know the it tends just to sort of move
along a snail space so you know in terms
of actually getting more bang for our
buck wouldn't be better to actually find
other projects throughout the rest of
the country that would actually you know
give us that level of productivity that
level of growth that again your
government wants
um I don't believe so uh Mr Chapman and
the reason I don't believe so is is a
very straightforward one which is that
if you look at
the reason why countries like France or
Japan or Germany have been able to
spread their growth much more evenly
than we have in the UK it's because they
are better connectivity if you live in
Osaka you don't think that in order to
grow your business and to get big bucks
salaries you have to move to Tokyo you
can get on a bullet train you can be in
Tokyo in three hours and you can be back
the same day if you want to and that's
why ultimately the answer if we want
growth to be evenly spread out is better
connectivity across the country and
that's why I've been very careful to
protect the funding foreign
is there seems to be a level of
non-connectivity between Department as
well you know we had the leveling up
debacle towards the end of last year you
know where cities like Glasgow was
formerly the the Second City of the
Empire didn't receive any leveling up
funds at all and yet in Glasgow they've
got some of the most drastic uh levels
of
um poverty and so on between different
areas and uh you know the the ability of
people to to keep in good health and so
on so how how is that sending the right
kind of message to people all over the
country if one Department uh that I know
you're not responsible for but one
department has gone off in a completely
tangent uh to how you want to see growth
across the whole country and I think
we've seen it as well and the the way
that they
um the the tax subsidy was given June
for pensions for example you know you
mentioned earlier twenty thousand pounds
was the average wage yeah there's people
people that live around this area who
can put sixty thousand Pounds into their
their pension Port you know that's
that's a level of inequality that is
just beyond appeal
um well I will write to you because I
think that is not a fair
characterization of the work being done
by Michael ghost Department let me write
you with what's happening on leveling up
projects in Glasgow but it is true that
in the leveling up announcement that we
made recently we did not give money to
places that already received leveling up
funding because we wanted to spread the
benefits of leveling up more widely but
let me also say that people on low
incomes in Glasgow need their NHS to be
functioning they need doctors to be
turning up to work and they do not need
doctors retiring early because of the
way the pension tax system works and so
it's very very important we had within
hours of my budget announcement doctors
contacting the BMA saying that they
wanted to come back out of retirement
and I think the um the benefits to
people on all incomes of having an NHS
where there are a doctor is able to do
the operations that need to be done is
going to be substantial
thank you unless that sex beautifully
into Anthony yeah thank you chair and
I'm indeed going to ask about the
taxation of Pensions and I should
declare it the outset that I do have in
the past call to the abolition of the
lifetime allowance I didn't think you'd
do it but uh glad that you did but I
think it's obviously right to probe your
reasoning behind it uh and obviously the
proximate cause was the doctors that you
just mentioned big issue in my
constituency retiring early but um you
you had been in discussions uh with the
BMA and others about a specific NHS
scheme uh and there's been called a
criticism that you
um widened it out to everyone uh why and
the objective is not the question is not
as torson Bell said of the resolution
foundation not the question the exam
question is not whether it was a good
objective to encourage doctors to carry
on working but was there a better more
cost-effective way of doing it so why
did you go for the whole big gun
approaching
um for two reasons
um firstly because a doctor's only
scheme would have been more regressive
because it would have helped all doctors
whereas the measures I announced don't
help the 20 wealthiest of doctors
and would have actually cost potentially
almost as much as the scheme that we
announced that applies for everyone but
secondly because as you know we've been
discussing earlier in this session we do
have a growing problem as the bank of
England Governor said of people in their
50s taking early retirement and actually
it is very important for the economy
that we remove barriers to people
working and we change the social
contract so that people feel when they
come to my sort of age that if they want
to carry on working they can maybe it's
not full time maybe some of it is
working from home maybe some of it is
combined with volunteering
or leisure activities but we remove
those barriers and the abolition of the
LTA achieves that objective as well
one one of the one of the points of the
resolution foundation made and we had
them in here uh last week uh was that if
you look at the the groups who would
benefit from this uh according to the
National the wealth and asset survey uh
about half from the public sector and
half the private sector that about 20
were in banking and finance uh and they
said uh it it was unfair that this was a
basically tax cut for people working in
finance as many of them as almost as
doctors is that is that a concern of
yours well the financial services
industry in the UK employs 2.2 million
people pays 10 percent of our tax space
that's half the cost of the NHS and I
think we want to have a flourishing
Financial Services sector but we want to
have other sectors that are flourishing
as well like life sciences technology
advanced manufacturing and so on but it
is a benefit to everyone including
people of low income if we have an
economy that removes barriers to work
and that's not just the over 50s that's
young parents who have children and
might want to go back to work rather
than give up work when they have a young
child which is why the child care
reformers matter it's disabled and
long-term sick people who now are able
to work in a way that one could never
have imagined a decade ago and it's also
job Seekers who we are giving more
support to to work there's one and a
half million of those they alone could
fill every vacancy in the economy so if
we can do that what the obr said as a
result of the budget was that this was
the biggest upward Revision in GDP
that they had ever given in a budget as
a result of government policies that
upward Revision in GDP makes it possible
to do all sorts of things that help
everyone particularly those on the
lowest incomes
in terms of how many people are actually
effects in the opr they said that they
expected to be 15 000 extra people would
go into work as a result of um scrapping
the lifetime allowance and uh various
analysts including I think again the
resolution Foundation but also the ifs
pointed out that would be 80 000 pounds
per job so it's a very expensive
intervention
um do you assume you accept those obr
figures it seems low to me but I'm just
wondering what you what your response is
to that uh analysis that it's 80 000
pounds per job well I respect the obr's
figures they're an independent forecast
it's their job to make a forecast their
Central forecasters that taken together
the labor Supply package will bring 110
000 more people into work but they also
say that
um they could bring 240 000 more people
into work
um and that those that hundred and ten
thousand figure
um they said that on the low end
scenario fifty thousand or fifty five
thousand the high end 240 000 and I
believe they said and it's more likely
to be on the higher side than on the
lower side going forward so they
recognize that there's a range of
outcomes and
um I recognize it's very difficult for
them to quantify what those outcomes are
but I'm hoping that we will see
significant upside in those numbers
and just add to that they also said that
sorry more individuals responding to the
pensions changes was one of the things
they pulled out that might push you
towards the 240 000 numbers that was an
example they gave that might drive you
higher
um
the there was some other sort of
commentary or criticism that actually
this could be used as an inheritance tax
loophole because obviously some forms of
Pensions are outside inheritance tax and
it could encourage people to transfer
large amounts of money into the the
pension before they die so they don't
have to pay their um their heirs don't
have to pay in Harrison's tax on it is
this something that you looked at and
something you might look at addressing
well what I point out is that we still
have an annual allowance so there's a
limit as to how much you can put into
your pensions Port every year and
um you still pay tax or your heirs pay
tax on the pension pot when they draw it
out at their marginal rate of tax so um
so you're not escaping tax uh you're
just paying it in a different way you
pay income tax correct which if you're a
lower rate payer is obviously a lot less
than uh inheritance tax correct you
paired at your marginal rate yeah
um I would urge you to the treasury to
look at the interaction between
inheritance tax and uh um pension taxes
I think there is some unusual
interactions there
um you mentioned you've also increased
your lifetime allowance the the annual
allowance by 50 to 60 000 a year and
that's uh uh obviously an increase now
but actually it was I think under the
last Labor government it was of course
for a million pounds a year which is it
seems extraordinarily high in respect um
I was just wondering what your rationale
was for increasing that I mean it was uh
I wasn't aware there was any pressure to
increase it or demand to be able to put
more in than forty thousand pounds a
year which is quite gen you have to be
pretty well paid to pay 40 000 pounds a
year into a pension
um well I might bring in cat actually on
that point because that was partly
because that was necessary if we were
going to solve the issue for doctors it
was the interaction of the LTA and the
AAA but yeah so we expected around 22
000 clinicians to exceed the annual
allowance and again it was one of the
factors that they said was guessing in
the way of them having sustained
long-term careers in in health so for
those 22 000 we hope that by raising it
to that threshold into two thousand
twenty two thousand would have exceeded
it within 23 24. and that's all annual
allowance yeah wow
and that was was that did that
discourage them from working again was
there any indication that that was the
case or they just reduced their payments
yeah but the evidence is mixed on that
and so we need to do further evaluation
um once the policy is up and running
yeah have you the the tape rate was
obviously reduced the allowance at a
high a higher incomes over 200 000 I
think 150 000 goes down to 10 000 pounds
a year have you looked at the impact of
all that
uh we I think we have explicitly but and
I'm sure that really is in the top one
percent territory I mean that is that
it's yeah we can write to you on that
all my questions thank you okay thank
you Anthony Emma thank you chair I have
a few questions we super grateful if we
could be as concise as possible
um the FSB were really critical of the
budget and they said and I quote we
cannot hide our disappointments on
investment and labor market the measures
that small businesses were looking for
are missing it's almost as if the
government thinks that small businesses
don't exist and just in the past week
there's been a local restaurant close in
my constituency Crafters there's been a
local shop
over the moon sentence at risk of
closing and these are typical of a
number of small businesses closing
around and obviously I know your
priority is to grow the economy but the
economy can't grow if small businesses
are closing so I wonder if you could
just briefly speak on further to what
was announced in the budget are there
any other plans to support small
businesses or to prevent the closures
and the rate of closures that we're
seeing at the moment well um I was
surprised by that comment by the fsp
because I listened carefully to what
they said they would like to see in the
budget and for example when it comes to
investment
we introduced only a few months ago the
annual investment allowance which means
that
99 of all businesses
can fully expense all their Capital up
to a million pounds but that covers 99
of businesses but also because they said
very clearly that child care was an
issue for small businesses as did the
CBI for larger businesses
we are doing an ongoing consultation on
what can be done to simplify these uh
small business tax regime and we will
look at that very carefully but the the
biggest point I would make for small
businesses is that having run one myself
for 14 years before I came into politics
is that the most important thing is
stability
and what we were able to say in the
budget is that as a result of the
decisions we've taken we are not now
predicted to go into recession this year
and that's very very important for small
businesses are saying to me
the um Hospitality businesses are saying
to me it's it's concerns around vat and
it's around energy costs and it's around
the costs of keeping those businesses
open I mean there's a number of I don't
know what the data shows and then I'm
speaking like dosley hairdressers
closing all over the place because the
energy costs of running a hairdressers
I've gone up so great what I'm what I'm
what I'm looking for
is any good news you can give these
local businesses that things are going
to get a bit better well I think three
bits of good news the first is that
um the we're helping families over three
thousand pounds on average per family
and that is helping the spending power
of families that are the customers of
small businesses secondly for businesses
themselves the energy bills discount
scheme will mean up to 400 pounds help
for retailers with their bills up to 2
300 pounds for pubs with their bills and
thirdly the oer and now the bank of
England as well saying that we're not
going to go into recessions I think you
put all those things together and for
small businesses the Outlook is a lot
more positive than it was just a few
months ago I really don't think they're
feeling it but one of the places
obviously you could get some money from
to support small businesses is around
the tax Gap and I was concerned to
either there's investment in hmrc's debt
management capability but nothing for
compliance work and obviously the latest
tax Gap stands around 32 billion and the
tax Gap resulting from fraud has
increased from 43.7 to 45 percent of the
tax fraud Gap standing at
14.4 billion why has more funding not
been announced for hmrc compliance work
well we have been increasing the funding
going to hmrc for compliance work over
recent years and we are expecting to get
a lot more income as a result of that
but I will write you with exact details
of what we're doing on that I would just
add Chancellor that we announced
significant funding in the Autumn
statement to tackle compliance and the
obr acknowledged that that would help
tackle the tax cap as well but we can
add more detail the tax evasion the hmrc
said is becoming much more complex more
sophisticated more International and
more digitally enabled and of course and
it's revealed that UK residents hold a
570 billion in tax Havens the rebel
accountant whose book is out now says
hmrc can't compete with firms that it
needs to investigate because the people
who they'd like to employ will actually
go into work in private business for
every person prosecuted for tax fraud in
the UK between 2009 and 2019 23 times as
many were pursued for benefit fraud so
why does benefit fraud continue to be
prioritized over tax fraud when tax
fraud brings more money into the
treasury exactly the kind of money that
we need to be giving to support our
local businesses we don't prioritize one
over the other we want to stop them both
and we put maximum effort into both why
is one invested why is one receiving
more money than the other one when a tax
board come compliance money brings in
more money to the treasury it doesn't
make sense
we put in the money that we think is
necessary to do the job and it's
sometimes a different amount of money
required for different jobs but they are
both equal priorities we are against all
fraud
um all tax evasion and will continue to
work very hard to reduce the attack
18 pounds back and when you invest in
benefit forward you get six times so
much back it seems illogical at a time
when the government is desperate for
money when small businesses are
desperate for money that we are not
maximizing making people pay the money
that they they owe we are okay so the
newly announced increases in r d
benefits for smes along with the added
complexity of the rules do you think
that's going to affect the previously
anticipated reduction in fraud and ever
in r d tax relief
I believe so
um because we had a system where there
was some abuse and the system we've
created uh there's a clear Gateway in
terms of your r d intensity that allows
you to go through and because of that
we're able to put in checks and balances
to make sure that we really are
supporting companies particularly in
life sciences but also some technology
companies that are the future for the
country but are loss making at early
stages and so I think we've got a much
more robust system are you confident
this new r d relief won't also be abused
and cost more than the 500 million
forecast because we've had evidence on
the committee at the rate of abuse and I
gave the example of a company that was
saying it was doing research into making
cocktails and received r d tax relief
so do you think that you've managed to
get a grip on that problem or are you
expecting fraud to continue in the way
it has done previously well in this they
are spending uh more than 40 percent of
their turnover researching cocktails and
loss making
um they wouldn't be able to get off the
starting blocks but I'm very confident
the system we put in place
will make it next to impossible for
cocktail makers to be claiming r d tax
relief that would be that would be
progress and when you appeared before
this Committee in November last year you
told me when we were questioning each
other publicly that you were willing to
meet with the TUC leaders to discuss
issues around funding and public sector
pay you actually stated I am I am very
happy to meet with the head of the TUC
the TUC wrote to you on the 7th of
December on the 20th of January asking
you for a date and receive no response
they also wrote to your special advisor
on the 1st of March and received no
response as a person who he wants to be
seen as a man of his word why haven't
you met them
um well I am very happy to meet Paul
Nowak I'm looking forward to meeting him
at some stage the dates you mentioned
were in the run-up to the budget which
was obviously
it's a busy time for any Chancellor and
also it was in the context of public
sector pay disputes where I didn't think
that that meeting would be productive
because there are discussions going on
with individual union leaders and
individual sectors of state and I think
it would have added a complexity to
those discussions but I he's someone
that I would like to meet in due course
when when I questioned you in November
your
I'm happy to meet
them I'm happy to meet them
because but I can't meet them now
because of these various reasons and I'm
sure you'll you understand Chancellor
why it seems concerning when a
Chancellor makes a promise on a select
committee that promise isn't fulfilled
I'm looking forward to meeting him at
the appropriate time
quickly is going to be the appropriate
program are we talking within this
Parliament within before Reese there so
you know how when is the appropriate
time
um I will meet him as soon as I am able
and when it's appropriate to do so and I
think you have to leave it to me to find
a time that works for uh his diary and
for my diary but I made that commitment
to you and I will honor it
thank you thank you Emma and now someone
who's been bursting to come in yeah and
my outbursts are because I don't know if
you appreciate Chancellor that most
people of all political Persuasions what
drives them mad about governments and
politicians is Big offers and small
delivery smoke and mirrors and what I
want to suggest to you a lot of your
child care plan is precisely that when
my friend
Natasha and Pete were looking at the
your budget statement they were
delighted they thought they were going
to be helped with child care for
two-year-old Noah because that couple
pay more in child care for their
two-year-old than they pay on their
mortgage
only when they looked at the detail
they aren't going to get any extra and
when the Sutton trust a charity as you
all know that looks at Social Mobility
looked at your package 20 of the poorest
families were not going to be able to
access the 38 hours and when we look at
the numbers of nine month to
two-year-olds there'll be 1 369
000 more or less and only 640 of those
would be eligible for the child care so
there will be more children not eligible
and I was just interested about your
timing because of course September 2025
when all those children will become
eligible to 30 hours is two and a half
years away which is conveniently after
the next general election are you just
hopeful you won't have to be there to do
it
not at all and we are implementing these
child care plans which are the biggest
increase in child care provision I think
in my lifetime
we're implementing these plans as
quickly as we can get the market to cope
with the additional capacity that will
be needed
um
no no it's my opportunity to ask the
questions
um the I would accept that if it wasn't
the case that
5400 nurseries closed in 20 20 21 and
that the amount of money you're giving
this year to try and meet the problem
that nurseries have in funding the
existing free child care places is only
240 million when the women's budget
group think that you need to spend 1.8
billion and that well-known trotskiest
organization the CBI think you need to
spend 1.6 billion so how are you
boosting that interest that the industry
the nursery providers if you are not
giving them the money to actually meet
the places that now exist and back to
the women's budget group who we are
really grateful to they tell us in order
to bring in your plans for 2025 it's
going to cost 9.4 billion and you're
allocating 4.2 so less than half of what
they need to keep going okay so now
we're going to do this to Ronnie's
sketch thing where I answer the question
you asked me before which you didn't
allow me to answer and then I will
answer that question because you asked
about two years
I know you do but yeah as a member but
you need to allow me to answer them and
um you talked about two-year-old Noah
um when Noah turns three he will be
entitled to 30 hours of free child care
that was introduced in 2013. If someone
becomes pregnant today by the time uh
their child finishes maternity and
paternity leave they will be entitled to
15 hours of free help it's not the case
that people will only benefit in
September of 2025 the first cohort of
people will benefit next April and then
there'll be another cohort who benefit
next September and um just in terms of
uh you're saying children aren't
eligible let's be absolutely clear
unless there is someone in the household
earning more than a hundred thousand
pounds every household is eligible it's
both let me pair it if both parents are
working correct well that is the purpose
of that is the purpose of these reforms
it's to remove the barriers to work for
people who want to work and let me
answer your last question just while I'm
at
if you're training to be
a question um you talked about the
support that's going into the sector
it's five billion pounds a year that is
a huge amount of additional support
that's going up but we need to build up
to it gradually because there are
thousands of Nursery places
and if I thought that this was a sincere
effort I would have thought you'd have a
Workforce plan I mean this is an
industry where something like 90 000
people left it since 2018. it's an
industry where we rely on very young
women to earn five pounds an hour so
they are younger they do not qualify uh
for the minimum living wage and that's
how nurseries get by so what is the plan
to make sure that people want to stay in
this industry and care for our children
rather than to leave and stack shelves
in a supermarket which is what they're
actually doing well um we announced a
number of things in the budgets to
improve the supply of labor to this
Market including incentives for child
minders and child minder agencies
and we are having a big discussions
about education is having a big
discussion because this is a a big
delivery challenge which I know they are
determined to rise to but the simple
answer to your question is that we have
said to the child care industry that
we're putting 5 billion pounds a year on
the table of additional public money
into improving Child Care provision we
want to work with you to make sure that
we can deliver this promise because we
think it's very important for the
economy and it's going to help thousands
they are serious they're saying to you
they need 20 that
you're asking them to deliver
well
um some people said that but what most
people said was that this was an
enormous step forward some of the
campaigners have been campaigning for
this uh cried when they heard the news
because they said this is something that
they never imagined they were going to
get
um but we believe it is very very
important so I fully accept there are
delivery challenges there's happiness
now because they will not be able to
cross subsidize free places with fully
with fully paid for places and to make
up the difference so the fact I'm sure
you get emails certainly I do of mums
and dads who say I've had a letter for
my Nursery they're closing next week
next month and for some of them the next
day because they simply cannot afford to
carry on well
um there have been Nursery closures but
this is a big step in the right
direction for all nurseries and I think
anyone reasonable looks at what the
government's announced and the money
that we're putting behind this enormous
expansion of child care provision can
see that we're absolutely serious about
transforming the lives for parents up
and down the country with reforms that
will mean up to six and a half thousand
pounds reduction in the child care costs
that people face for a child under five
that is a big big step in the right
direction
you need to get nurseries and you need
the people who want to work in the
industry
no plan for that at all well um I think
you know the budget was a couple of
weeks ago the department for Education
now know they have got the funding and
they will put in place the plans and I'm
sure you'll hear from them uh the detail
of how we're going to deliver but yes we
recognize it's a big challenge that's
why we're taking two and a half years to
roll out the plans in full but that
doesn't mean that we're waiting uh until
then uh in uh next year September of
next year a million parents will be
benefiting from this package so that's a
big step forward
thank you very much everyone um can I
just opt further to that
um thank you Chancellor just to be clear
in terms of the rollout and the
workforce plan and so on are you saying
it is now for the DFE to determine
exactly how this will be delivered
correct thank you yeah thank you and the
bell will go in the final set of
questions
um but we will just go straight through
the Bell uh Anne-Marie
um Chancellor there are clearly two very
important sectors uh which for the
future of the UK will really matter one
is the energy sector and you've already
identified very clearly the advances
we've made with regard to Renewables and
the second is life's answers
the challenges with the energy sector
are that given all of those changes the
structure and the payment mechanisms
fundamentally need to be changed and the
government is already looking at that
in this mix the challenge for businesses
who do not have the same support through
off gem to regulate our pricing
mechanisms to ensure that there is
fairness in the system
they are therefore faced with a market
where the thought increases that they
have been asked to pay are extortionate
if I take the
non-domestic I wrote to you following
your invitation with examples of
constituency businesses and protective
bodies just to show you how bad it is
sadly I've not yet had a response I set
out for you very clearly that some of
these businesses are looking at 400
increase I have a local school in Devon
the increases 800 percent
now I value what you have done for
businesses
I value the new scheme but the new
scheme represents only three percent of
what was on offer before
and you have the possibility for those
businesses which are
high energy users to apply and receptor
scheme yet to be announced and any
further information on that greatly
received
but the challenge therefore Chancellor
is if we are supporting our businesses
what can you will you do differently
could you look at two things one whether
or not you could sensibly extend rather
than the three percent
continue the existing scheme which is
much more generous and look as I've
asked you before whether or not that
list of high energy users might include
pubs and the like I appreciate they get
and they have had lots of support on
business rate relief but they are really
struggling I would welcome your comment
and what support you could offer above
and beyond beyond what we've already
provided
well I think um I I first of all I fully
recognize
the pressures that are faced by some
businesses and the question is what the
right Solutions so as you rightly point
out we we've given business what will
amount to I think eight billion pounds
of support
this financial year and next so a very
significant amount of support for
businesses with their energy bills
um but
um the wholesale gas prices are now
below the level they were when Ukraine
was invaded
and so
the businesses that seem to have been
caught are the businesses that renewed
their contracts in a period where prices
were higher before they fell
and that seems to me to be not the
question of subsidy but a question of
whether the market is functioning in the
way that it should and that's why off
gem have agreed to do an investigation
that gave me an update on their
investigation they said they were in
fact concerned about the way that market
is working and we await to hear their
conclusions but I think that is the
right issue because as you know that's
not a regulated market but off gem are
looking into whether it is functioning
in the way it should and we obviously
have concerns with gas prices having
fallen to below you pre Ukraine Invasion
levels that something isn't quite right
chance that that's helpful technology is
while this is being reviewed
businesses are still having to pay
extortionate bills
and it is because of that delay that I
think my my ask is and I'm not expecting
an answer today but perhaps you might
write to me to look up what you might do
even if you had phased rather than cut
support that would have helped so let me
in the time remaining just turn to Life
Sciences Life Sciences as you said in
the budget and quite rightly is
absolutely Mission critical to the
Future for this country and you did make
some very welcome reforms which you've
already outlined and you also looked at
what you're looking for mhra our
regulator to look at how we could
provide better support
but you will know particularly given
your previous role as health secretary
but one of the biggest challenges is the
medicine pricing Arrangement the
voluntary pricing agreement you will
also be aware that that is coming up for
review this year and you'll also be
aware that because of such concern as
it's been referred to already at this
hearing some businesses have effectively
said this is not a country that we feel
really supports life sciences now that
is not a message that we want it is not
I think what this government believes
can I ask you therefore a chancellor
you are the only person who really
understands both sides of this because
of your previous role to look at this
pricing agreement and negotiation and
recognize that while of course we need
to keep medicine prices low
at the same time if we do not properly
incentivize and reward the life sciences
businesses they will vote with their
feet and that is something we absolutely
must not do will you assure me that you
will get engaged in this you will look
at both sides and look at something
which is fair while recognizing the cost
constraints that I entirely understand
well I can absolutely reassure you that
I'm engaging with the life science
Industry on this issue I've had a series
of meetings I think I've discussed it
with
the leaders of our major UK life science
companies on a number of occasions
and of course we have to have something
that works for them
and also works for the NHS
and I think we have to recognize that a
complete solution is about more than the
prices that the NHS pays for drugs it's
about things like how easy it is to do
clinical trials in the NHS where
um we have not been doing as well
recently as we were during the pandemic
and pre-pandemic and we want to look at
that issue
and it's about
things like speed to market for new
drugs where the reforms are announced in
the budget well I hope make a difference
but I'm following those negotiations
very closely and um you know I'm very
hopeful that we can find a solution that
works for taxpayers and for the NHS
but also reassures the life science
Industry that we are very committed to
sustaining our position as Europe's
biggest life science sector
and would you meet with me Chancellor to
discuss the issue because as you can
imagine I have been lobbied right left
and center and I believe that we need to
find a way forward and I'd like to see
how
I could help come up with a solution
which actually might work of course I'd
be delighted too thank you I'm Marie
John you've got a quick supplementary do
you typically one of your growth Heroes
was also Financial Services John and you
you recognize that the city of London
generates more than 10 percent of the
UK's GDP now the stock market is only a
part but it is a gateway to a lot of
services whether it be Finance Insurance
Legal Services derivatives and so forth
yet what we're seeing is a list a lot of
companies deciding to de-list and we've
seen the equity Market since 2007 Fall
by a third whereas others have risen
particularly the U.S with their total
value I'm referring to I mean part of
the problem very quickly is that
following the financial
crisis
Regulators in this country at olds with
many others around the world encouraged
our Pension funds
the de-risk and reduce their Equity
exposure is this something that you
could look at because the stock market
is ailing at the moment and it is such
an important gateway to the square mile
as a whole you know we've talked about
crh we've talked about arm listening in
the states rather than here and could I
encourage you to think outside the box
when it comes to things like perhaps
stopping the tax penalties when it comes
to equity financing and perhaps dusting
down the hill review
which now is two years old and having a
look at their recommendations
well I met Lord hill yesterday
and we had a very good discussion about
his reforms which we think are very
sensible and I think he believes they
are being largely being implemented so
hopefully no need to dust down that
review because I think it's happening
and I agree with your point about
Pension funds and we're doing a lot of
work on Pension funds that's another
piece of work that I intend to have
completed by the Autumn statement and I
had a meeting this week with the Lord
mayor to discuss that he's a very
enthusiastic advocate of reformer
approach and breakfast with the Pension
funds industry as well earlier this week
to discuss
that very issue so absolutely committed
to quickly would you mind would you mind
meeting with me about this issues oh
that's very kind thank you
[Laughter]
but just a couple of quick last
questions it's been announced that you
have reversed the Prime Minister when he
was Chancellor's decision to issue a
non-fungible token through the Royal
Mint what why why did you do that well I
think it's a question of demand I think
uh we always want to be at The Cutting
Edge
in the UK um in terms of new technology
but um the world has changed
significantly since then and uh we're
not convinced that the demand is going
to be there in the same way and then
final one for me is around your
experience working with a prime minister
who has previously been Chancellor so
how Hands-On was the Prime Minister in
developing this budget well it was very
constructive because I have a prime
minister who knows just how difficult it
is to put together a budget package in
very challenging circumstances and he
was able to help and support and guide
me and I think was a big part of the
success of the overall budget package in
showing the country how we are going to
increase our long-term growth rate
slightly different answer from the one
he gave me yesterday at the liaison
committee where he said he was deferring
entirely to you Chancellor so
um
I think um that's been quite
enlightening but um we've left us with
lots of things to follow up on uh and
lots of things that this committee will
continue to work on uh in scrutinizing
your budget but thank you very much for
your time and your officials time today
order order